so taking social responsibility comes at
a price and not everyone is ready to pay
it let's talk about this with get
plucker from the battlesman foundation
in guterslaw first of all welcome thank
you very much for joining us on the show
today now we've just seen two great
examples of companies
taking social responsibility seriously
would you say they are the exception to
the rule no um
they're not the exception almost every
company is aware of this and they know
the advantages of
being integral in business cases so
everybody is
is keen to be good in business you may
say
right okay but the definition of what it
means to be good in business uh that
varies from company to company now here
in germany for example a lot of
companies seem to believe in this doing
good and make it known but then again
for them corporate responsibility
is identical with social expenditure
mostly followed by other donations and
then of course staff leave taking on
work-life balance philosophy like the
ones we've seen the reports now that
seems to be sort of not really on their
minds so in your words what is corporate
social responsibility yes to my point of
view it would be better to see it under
a non-monetary angle this this point it
is very easy for companies to spend
money but it's much more complicated to
do something with your employees in the
social fear so
why not doing a corporate volunteering
uh event for your team so that they can
learn something about the stakeholders
in the social
area of your of your company okay well
that's a nice idea uh but what would be
the incentive for a company to do that
this is hr yeah so the the resources as
the employees will think other in
another way about the
surroundings of your company so this is
very important for you to learn
something about your customers about the
people that surrounds you but what is in
it for the company now most companies
and there is no shame in saying that
they need to make a profit it's all
about earning money so taking on
corporate social responsibility for a
company there has to be something uh
below the bottom line as well yes the
nice thing about that is uh that it's
that it helps to to learn something and
to be more adaptive towards a customer
so it helps and innovation to be
innovative is something that helps to be
to have more success talking of the
customer or the customer obviously can
also to a certain extent dictate how a
company functions we've seen
unfortunately too many disasters like
collapsed factories in bangladesh with a
high death toll and for a while it
seemed that customers were very aware
and stayed away from these shops that
were known to produce there how long
does that memory last
not very long
people are very conservative so
people can do much more to be more
adaptive to to corporate social
responsibility what what can they do yes
you need not to go by car to the bakery
when it's just around the corner you can
go by foot so
we all we have to change so and
it helps to be more aware of what you're
doing from day to day and so csr is a
topic for customers too okay
social responsibility starts at home i
take it thank you very much for joining
us today